better CGM Allison the Justice League
and that ain't nothing
[Music]
involving dogs in which the dogs can
talk but only to each other it's kind of
like look who's talking but with dogs I
guess it would be Look Who's Talking Now
Will Ferrell plays an adorable little
dog he just wants his master to call him
a good boy a good dog and well this guy
just
well he hates dogs
I personally don't trust him simply on
that fact a standard I just kind of give
to everybody fictional or otherwise so
after being dumped by his human he teams
up with a little Boston Terrier voiced
by Jamie Foxx they get their friends a
crew of four dogs and they're gonna get
back so this little dog can
bite his former Masters deck off you
know sometimes a simple revenges are
just the most effective and usually I
like having my pups in a video about
pups but they are increasingly afraid of
coming into this room in which I film in
either my house is haunted or the
simpler explanation they're like yeah
[__] you you're not exploiting us for
algorithm find another thumbnail I do
respect them for that also don't want to
scare the [__] out of them for the sake
of a thumbnail but b-roll footage with a
cell phone they're fine with that so
there you go now this movie effectively
does its job well it's a raunch comedy
and I was amused throughout I don't know
about drop on the floor laugh out loud
moments the scene where they're tripping
balls like that would have been funnier
if I didn't see it in the trailer but I
knew it was coming I knew the entire
stick well for the most part okay there
was actually a scene in which I did
laugh out loud it's one of those it's
one of those comedic moments where you
see the punch line coming you know where
it's going and that's what makes it
funny the reveal not nearly as funny as
it going down but as the whole crew of
dogs is great Will Farrell and Jamie
Foxx fantastic that means Will Ferrell
and Jamie Foxx solid talent I don't know
how much of it was ad-libbed I would be
shocked if the answer was none but man
the dialogue the banter back and forth
Just flowed like honey a lot of dick and
piss jokes usually I'd roll my eyes
couple times I did but it's dogs pee
makes sense raise your hand if you're a
dog owner who cleaned up dog pee today
I know don't be shy there were a couple
of awkward moments which just feels like
a scene existed for one joke and that
was the purpose of the scene and now we
move on rather than a scene exists the
characters are going through it and a
comedic moment happens in that scene in
a more organic fashion but the scene
itself doesn't just exist for the joke
it's actually part of the larger whole I
prefer that this movie had a couple
moments it's just like no the scene is
for the joke and when the joke ends the
scene ends I think it's an hour and a
half it felt like it was a little longer
than an hour and a half so you could
have trimmed a few minutes off of it
this is a review after all we got to
start nitpicking at a point if that
annoys you well I got you covered here's
some b-roll footage of some 10 year old
puppy there you go life is good again
yep the Googles is telling me the
movie's about an hour and 33 minutes I
feel like 10 minutes or so could have
been shaved off that but the movie is
undeniably heartfelt in the sense that
it is written tailored and exists for
dog lovers cat lovers well they tried
that and now we circled back around a
dog to be fair I love both had a pretty
awesome cat growing up his name was
Martin but it is absolutely tailor-made
for dog lovers this is ironic humor in
the film that addresses dog behavior and
human behavior and how they see us and
the weird things they do and why you
know I enjoy that because you got to
scratch your head and just wonder why
sometimes and to the heartfelt core
wrapped in the raunch comedy shell I
felt there was a solid message about
abusive relationships and Breaking Free
of that I feel Strays did it better than
Renfield the raunch element of this
raunch comedy felt a little heavy-handed
at times but it does have more positive
than negative this film respectfully
understands the truth which is dogs
they're just better than humans I had
myself a good time no alcohol required
all right so Strays have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to say more
[Music]